vous c'est quoi alors si isabelle il
avait visité semaines susan suis à vous
aurez j'adore ce prénom suivi cette
semaine
merci c'est mon fils
justement ça vous savez pourquoi j'ai
appelé mon fils sinon pas du tout à
cause du sol j'ai dit tout
tous les téléspectateurs attendent qu'on
appelle tous les jours qu'est ce qui se
passe en syrie
alors j'ai regardé sur internet pour
voir s'ils arrêtent un miller pendant
que toi
et alors il n'y en a pas
[Musique]
pourquoi moi je suis venu quoi tu sais
ce soir autant amour ma chérie je t'aime
mon chéri je t'aime fort tu veux dès que
rien n'a rien à me demander si ça ne
[Rires]
leur fait envie que ça va changer quoi
c'est vrai ah bah ouais à l'adolescence
il va changer mais maintenant il a
exactement le même discours il a 18 ans
ont fait du mal vont au lycée mais bon
alors que faire genre à pleurer comme ça
commence bien l'émission commence bien
mais ça va me concentre mieux
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]